feels for him to see these tank changes
i want to now take the opportunity to
welcome
to our stream obviously prolific
streamer
cupcakes obviously we see playing a
multitude of fps titles including
overwatch
uh great to have you with us cupcake a
lot of news today we're continuing to
tease more out of these devs slowly
i'd love to get some of your thoughts on
what we have so far
oh man i really like seeing all the new
like hero looks and like the map visuals
and the ui updates have been really cool
especially as like a support player
i'm seeing a lot of little like ui
updates for like support heroes and i'm
really excited about them
so yeah absolutely you and me both
obviously i'm a support mate as well so
i'm looking forward to teasing
a little bit more out of our out of our
devs not only of course about
maybe supports but a little bit more
about overwatch too and of course yes we
will be showing
uh another map in just a moment so let's
take the opportunity to uh to sort of
bring
uh these these devs back in of course
i'll see
uh jeff and dion have given us some uh
great thoughts so far because something
that was teased at blizzcon online
uh and we got to see a little bit of was
actually the hero looks right overwatch
2 is
you know it's a game that's set a little
bit further sort of
in the future as far as we can tell and
this is reflected
in what the heroes actually look like i
don't know if deon jeff if you can
sort of speak to that because uh it's
not just a like a a jazzy
tech upgrade but something you know we
can see the passage of time being
implied with some of these new looks
yeah that's part of it is the passage of
time you can see bro
reinhardt is a little older i think
there's a
sneak peek at a few characters that um
there's a bit of age difference on them
as well a bunch of guys are part of
overwatch now so they
have access to cooler tech in their
outfits
uh it's just we're having fun kind of
like
in a way to show these guys have
upgraded their equipment
they're ready to do battle in this new
world uh fire here with their new
overwatch gear
so that she has the armor that fits the
overwatch team
uh yeah and just reaper is pretty
amazing as well
there's definitely feeling of them
looking sort of more high-tech in a
sense as well yeah so
i mean you know i love that you kind of
you kind of this is cheeky you're kind
of teasing uh little bits of the story
or how the world changes as we go so
that's just
you know building my appetite up to to
sort of see more about how the world is
changing and what all these
heroes are up to i mean you see
obviously widowmaker's got a change of
hairstyle as well
um tell us about what the development
process
on these changes is like because i think
it was sort of mentioned that there's
sort of a new tech available to
developers to sort of bring
these characters to life but i'd love to
know how you go about
refreshing or revamping or update some
of these hero looks
yeah we have a lot of cool very really
cool engine up
upgrades that you could see in some of
those shots
a lot of better detail the characters
skin feel more natural
their hair has a really awesome shader
and it just it you know it's still
stylized but it just feels much more
real
almost like you could touch it this is
in the environments as well there's
tons of nice detail we've upgraded the
lighting engine
so shadows are better all these things
are just to make the world feel much
more
immersive more dynamic and more animated
things in the world
uh the characters have the cool tech
gear and
details that we weren't able to do
before until we kind of
turned tuned knobs in the engine and
so we're suddenly playing with this
maintaining overwatch style
keeping the game performance smooth but
you know upgrading everything to the
overwatch 2 level
i'm curious about like the new the new
upgrades to the skins and like just the
heroes themselves
and you guys have all the skins from all
the different heroes from
overwatch and like how challenging it is
to bring them
in and like update their looks as well
like is that an easy process or is it
like tedious to make them all look
just as good that's a great question um
so a lot of the tech
we for example the skin shader will
apply to all the older skins as well
so our engine team is working hard to
kind of create a workflow that's easier
for the artist but it's still there's
there's a level of work there but
everything you see on these new 2.0
heroes the updated hair shaders updated
skin
uh detail maps these will all carry over
to the
older um heroes or the older skins so a
lot of stuff looks
even better than it did before um yeah i
can only imagine
there's a bit of work there to apply
some of the new new um techniques to
those guys but
it's a beautiful upgrade to practically
every single skin in the game
so it'll be fun for players to see
is it going to be possible to like add
more customization
like with this new technology like
unlocking different like color schemes
or something like that or like special
weapon variations even for like
certain achievements or something like
that so we have more ways
to customize the way our heroes look
an amazing question but you have to wait
and see
what about like mixing and matching like
skins and weapons is that going to
be impossible like 11 from one skin
because like that would be so much fun
like you get creative with that can you
imagine
like oh man now i mean we're already
we're theorycrafting you know we're off
to the races here already
i'm like i have so many ideas there's a
lot of fun stuff in store
yeah you do have something new it's like
my favorite part is the visual
so well speaking of which okay dion has
uh a new hero
to show us dion do you want to talk us
through this one
yeah so this one will be
i think he's a torbjorn so this is
tourbillon 2.0
you can see here he's a little older he
has a
bit better technology and gear and
yeah he's uh the torbjorn we all know
and loves he's just
much more in advance uh he has a cool
very cool uh you can see the hair
shaving really well on his uh beard
but like imagine that but with like his
summer skin like weapon
like that's the kind of stuff i want to
see at some point
so that i mean you can you can
definitely see i mean some of the some
of the changes are big right they're
vibrant and obviously
you know you can definitely see the
passenger and some are subtle
you know it's the it's the patches on
the knees of his jeans it's the
connectors between
the hardware that he's using uh the
goggles that he has
um and i mean we can see this gregarious
uh attitude from him very clearly
displayed though i think that's very
much still been
brought to life and you know we want to
upgrade the characters
but we don't want to lose that
silhouette that's familiar to players
you know
he still looks like torbjorn from a
distance he just looks
better and more detailed up close but he
maintains that
silhouette we come to know and love and
like to shoot at
so um that's uh some of the extra
extra props the vfx team for doing some
like the next uh kind of 2.0 vfx on his
pack there looks great
right smoke coming off yeah it's a
serious modernization of
of you know yeah not just obviously how
his skins look but how he behaves in the
game and how he interfaces with the
world that he's put in
let's let's shift gear here and talk a
little bit more about our next map